ON OCTOBER  FIRST
HOW QUICKLY HE CAN GET OUT OF
TRAFFIC.
MATTHEWS GETS AWAY FROM THE CAN.
NYLANDER GET CROSS.
NYLANDER IN FRONT!
JUSTIN HOLL ON THE MOVE.
BACK IN, PASS!
AND ALLENIT.
ENGVALL.
ENGVALL IN!
AND HIT THE NET.
SPEZZA E LINE FOR
BRODIE AND ACROSS.
BIG SHOT STOPPED BYMATTHEWS?
FRONT!
SCORES!
>> Craig: IF YOU'RE ON AN THE P
IS DEEMED TO BE OFFSID JETS.
LOAD  GOOD PASS HERE.
SENT PITLICK BACK IN.
OFF FOR HOFFMAN.SAVARD!
AND NOW THE GAME IS TIED!
[ Cheering and Ap YOUR RESPONSI
BACK IN COMES EVANS.
JAKE EVANS THREADS IT THROUGH!
A STOP LAGESSON.
ALONG THE BOARDS CAUFIELD SCOOPS
IT OUT.
AND SUZUKI ON FACE OFF WIN BY K.
SHOT RIGHT ON.
MONTREAL'S GOT THE LEAD!
HE'S A ONE-SHOT SCORER.
GOT ALL KINDS OF ENERGY.
ANDDN.
BUT THEY HAVE TO LIKE WHAT
THEY'RE SEEING ASNG FOR
MIKHEYEV!
SHOT ON Graig: AS A COACH YOU N
MAKE A CHANGE TO CREATE A
AND A ONE TIMER RIGHT ON!OUBLE.
MICHAEL BUNTING ACROSS.
HERE'SRES!
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chris: AND THE GAME IS TIED
THE NET.
EDMUNDSON ENDS UP TAKING A
PENALTY RIGHT HERE ON SPOT!
DID YOU SEECRISSCROSS.
THE ONE TIMER RIGHT THERE.
RIGHT OFF, JUST THE BLOCKER AND
PART OF THE.
THREE CANADIENS INTO THE LEAFS
ZONE.
ALLEN.
BUT A SHORTHANDED CHANCE TOO.
HERE'S BUNTING AWAY THE PASS.
BUT HESs: TO SEAL IT WAY.
THEN A SPEED RACE.